Castlerock is a new series set to air on
hulu later this month based on the work
of Stephen King
it looks fantastic so I had to put this
video together to unpack some of the
really cool Easter eggs and references
to the novels so here we go the trailer
opens with a shot of Shawshank Prison
yes the same prison found in the 1994
film The Shawshank Redemption which was
based off the King novel Rita Hayworth
and the Shawshank Redemption if you
notice in the left corner the unusual
amount of mist very similar to that
found in King's novel the mist now is it
connected we'll just have to find out
for ourselves next we get a glimpse of
this mysterious man played by Bill
skarsgård who you may remember as penny
wise in the 2017 adaptation of Kings
novel it now in this series skarsgård
will not be playing the fear loving
clown rather who or what his character
is remains to be seen here we get
another aerial shot of Shawshank clearly
an homage to the film before were
introduced to Alan Pangborn played here
by Scott Glenn Pangborn was the
protagonist in Kings needful things and
was the sheriff of Castle Rock from 1981
to 1991 with a drink in his hand and
looking a little worse for wear I think
it's fair to assume that he's either
retired or long since left the force now
we have a quick clip that's just
chock-full of Kujo references here you
can see the headline of the Castle Rock
call the local newspaper found in
several King novels stating rabid dog
tears through town with the words for
victims underlying notice also the names
tad Trenton and Joe camber among others
who are characters in Cujo and this one
just speaks for itself here we have an
appearance by [ __ ] Spacek who's known
for our iconic role in Brian De Palma's
king adaptation of Carrie which by the
way if you haven't seen my video on
Carrie you should definitely check it
out then were sent to Juniper Hill a
psychiatric hospital featured in such
King novels as it insomnia
bag of bones and Gerald's game a
hospital which housed such characters as
Henry Bowers Nettie Cobb and Raymond Joe
bear we then get our first glimpse of
Molly strand played by melanie lynskey
who also played in a miniseries
adaptation of kings
rose-red she plays a real estate agent
in a few moments later we see an open
house sign with balloons eerily
reminiscent of it and if you listen
closely when this shot comes up you can
hear the faint laughter of children I
don't know about you guys but this just
looks like dreamcatcher now we get to an
unknown man feverishly digging into the
woods which gives me big Tommyknocker
vibes which for those of you who don't
know is about a town that gradually
falls under the influence of a
mysterious object buried in the woods
again a few moments later we're back in
the woods and what seems to be some sort
of telepathy which again is used in
Tommyknockers and other King novels dead
bird alert possibly sparrows which would
be a reference to the dark half in which
the protagonist can control birds and
here a few seconds later we see them
flying in the air the shot here is a
point of view of a casket possibly the
same casket we saw earlier with Molly
and the strange bandaged head people
chosen Jacobs who is also one of the
kids in it silver bullet anyone okay
maybe it's not silver but that would be
cool and here we have an iconic shot
clearly a homage to the bathroom scene
in it and even the opening of Carrie
here's a random shot of some chess
pieces featuring the King which just
might be a shout-out to Stephen King
himself and finally we have a brief
glimpse of this visitor badge which
looks like it could be for juniper Hill
it features a juniper tree and is
similar to the emblem / logo found on
the guard a few moments earlier so there
you have it did I miss anything I want
to hear from you below and be sure to
LIKE and subscribe Castle Rock premieres
on Hulu on July 25th with three episodes
I'm excited to see it I hope you are too
[Music]